hey guys welcome back to middle ground
i'm evan and this is our illustrious
editor brandon
hi um really quick before we jump into
the video we released another video on
our second channel tubely
which is a channel that we created for
you guys to get to know us the jubilee
team better this is a video pretty much
about the origin story of jubilee media
and it was filmed three years ago back
when we were freaking out that we
received half a million subscribers so
we've definitely come a long way
and you should definitely check it out
yep and a big thank you to skillshare
for sponsoring this episode
stick around after the episode to learn
how you can get two months of skillshare
premium for free and hear quickly about
one of my favorite classes
but first here's the episode
as i'm looking up i just see these three
lights
in like a triangular formation it just
moves without
you know any sound or anything then it
stops for
10 seconds or so and then just raises up
into the clouds and then just
disappears
oh my gosh
[Applause]
what is your opinion about aliens
they're real
we have an entire galaxy just of
so many different planets and stars the
odds of us being alone in the universe
are
almost non-existent do you think humans
have made contact with aliens already
i don't think the evidence shows that
i've had my own experience
when you tell this experience that
people do they typically believe you
yeah for the most part i have
encountered aliens
it's not like in person like they're
hanging out like they're not
dense like we are we're talking about
minimum of thousands if not millions or
billions
of light years away so the odds that
they have visited us is pretty
astronomical that they probably didn't
and may not visit us for millions of
years
i think it's pretty exciting unless
you're one of those people that's
getting visited at three in the morning
alone in your bedroom and getting walked
out to some craft for
sexual experimentation
my name is greg carlwood i host a
podcast called higher side chats in the
conspiracy
paranormal space and been doing it for
10 years so i've heard a lot of
interesting stories i'm luke nyas
i'm an i.t specialist and i've also had
my own experience which is kind of crazy
but
yeah hi i'm lauren i
have a blog um called
starseedhotspot.com
i'm someone who would identify as a
starseed and have had a lot of different
spiritual and paranormal experiences
hi my name is lynette i'm an actress and
i'm spiritually aware of myself and i
believe that you know
aliens are real i'm dominic andre
i am actually a mental health therapist
and a influencer
but um i've been in love with science
since i was a kid published by nasa and
i pretty much am an amateur astronomer
spencer marks
the author of the sci-fi book living
history and
also a senior investigator with the
center for inquiry investigations group
we investigate claims of the paranormal
all right can i get my folks who
feel like they have made personal
contact with aliens on the left
and then my people who have not on the
right
first prompt is i've seen a ufo
yeah oh welcome hello
actually yeah uh yeah i've seen one um
it was about 10 years ago um just right
before i
graduated high school and as i'm looking
up i just see
these three lights in like a triangular
formation there was no
body to it just the three lights and
they were like flickering almost like
a on fire or something like that i look
at my buddy and i
i say uh he's seeing this he sees it and
yeah it just it just moves without you
know any sound or anything just quiet
for about a minute
then it stops for 10 seconds or so
and then just raises up into the clouds
and then just disappears
well this is 10 years ago so it's like
drones weren't really a big thing you
know i've never seen a plane that could
hover or at least
hover and then not make a bunch of noise
so it's just it's a
something i can't explain honestly
um so for me as someone who is
a clairvoyant i'll see like dimensional
like overlapping
of things especially going through
what's called the kundalini awakening
um which was really intense and i had a
lot of different types of contact with
like aliens
through like astral projection as well
like i've
just like left my body seen my body like
laying there and went and visited other
dimensions
been on spacecrafts and like seen
different spacecrafts these are things
that like i can't explain and
they weren't dreams for me as an amateur
astronomer i do
see ufos but to clarify that ufo stands
for unidentified flying objects so for
me
yes i do see things that i don't know
what they are but my immediate
conclusion isn't aliens or intelligent
life my immediate conclusion is
what can i scientifically understand you
know we thought thunder was
gods and now we would easily explain it
to not being gods people will get
confused they
assimilate or they you know make ufo and
aliens you know one and i'm like that's
not the same thing um
that's a good point let's bring in our
disagreers
it would be disingenuous to say i've
ever seen one first
hand but because of what i do uh i've
had
plumbers come to the house you're like
oh what do you do i host a conspiracy
podcast
well let me tell you something you know
my uncle is a pilot
and he would never tell his superiors
this but he's seen this and this
and even the u.s navy has released
footage of ufos and said yeah these
crafts are real and we don't know what
they are
just a couple years ago it was in the
new york times certainly i've seen it
looked up and said oh i don't know what
that is but
i never once assumed that to be an alien
spacecraft
i actually am also a private pilot so i
i know how to identify aircraft
visually from the lighting pattern i'm
also an amateur astronomer and and
you know uh i looked up a thousand times
through a telescope and you can see like
some people might think
that object moves so fast it was bright
and you know was that a uh
a ufo well i know it's a satellite so um
i'm not worried about those things
there's a lot of people who say i've
seen aliens i've seen ufos
it's interesting that the aliens have
headlights yeah you don't want to crash
in the ground
i think i think that we we don't even
need those now i mean you know like
we can use the technology so it's
interesting that we always use like
human-like objects to do
there's like a catch-all you know what i
mean because it's like you said oh they
have headlights well maybe
yeah maybe they have lights but maybe
it's not so they can see there could be
a different purpose for it you know what
i mean
uh i'm not one to be a fiber you know
it's like
if i believe in something i'm i'm not
afraid to say it
you know even if people might think i'm
crazy or whatever you know because
it's it's just something that's so weird
and different
that i mean why would you make that up
aliens live among us today
this galaxy this universe is so vast and
wide
to believe that they aren't here now
it's kind of
dumb in my opinion some kind of
multi-dimensional thing i mean someone's
flying all those crafts that people see
out there
right i've never seen any that i know of
but i have interviewed a lot of
researchers who
have heard from people within the
government within the department of
defense that have said
that they are pretty confident that
that's a reality and that the
black budget goes to trying to keep some
kind of tabs on
this activity i have read some stuff
about
people being abducted into government
facilities area 51 things like that
if we're talking about like the
traditional sense of like an
alien they work with our government they
keep this matrix
operating you know and as someone who
identifies as a starseed i mean like
technically
i'm an alien that incarnated here
i guess i interpret it as living among
us i think of like
you know the reptilians where you know
they're in disguise and they're
assimilating into uh our society where
you could be an alien and you're just
not saying it you know what i mean i
really don't know
i don't know if you see him in the line
at starbucks but i do think for there to
be physical
experiences there's they're sharing the
planet with us
i just find the notion pretty
far-fetched i mean
why the secrecy if they want to learn
from us if we want to learn about them
they're why wouldn't they just step
forward and say here we are
i think we all obviously believe aliens
do exist here or statistically
which is fine but to say that that they
traveled here is another thing because
like with the roswell crash
very very unlikely to see someone be
able to do that ten thousand years
across the entire universe and then
crash immediately when we get here
well plus you look at the debris i mean
they have pictures of the debris it's
like literally balsa wood and you know
mylars
pictures they showed you but the point
is there's not
enough physical i you know if you're in
a spaceship it's not going to be three
pounds i've read a lot of books about
the chain of custody of that material
there's thousands of people who've had
experiences there's uh
dozens and dozens of crash stories that
are beyond rob as well i think that the
person writing the book has an incentive
financially to write about yes but is a
doctor less good because he makes money
being a doctor
aliens is kind of a loaded term i mean i
think of non-human intelligences
which could be things people experience
on psychedelics
i woke up one day a complete material
atheist some friends convinced me to try
salvia devanorum and then it was kind of
like an instantaneous
out of body experience and then that
felt
entirely natural it felt more normal
than waking life and then there were
a there was a male and female entity of
some kind and
they spoke to me they're like wow we're
surprised you're here i'm like i'm
surprised i'm here
and one was more cynical about the fact
that i wouldn't be there long and the
other one was just more excited about
being there at all
and the one was like well you know why
why are you even talking to this guy
he's going to be gone
he's going to be gone in just a few
minutes like but he's here now and
i'm convinced there's intelligences out
there that are non-human that we can't
interact with but
that kind of changed my life actually
i think people on the other side are
misinformed
i think the data for ufos and non-human
intelligence
is pretty strong i think you have to
really dive into it because it's not
being presented
on the news but when you look at it
there's no shortage of
really credible sources that have seen
some pretty incredible things
paul hellyer is the ex-defense minister
of canada
and he says hey there's these crafts
flying over and they're shooting our
nuclear facilities with some kind of
beam and disabling them
i mean that's a fairly credible source
right well
look anecdotal evidence is some evidence
but it's not
strong evidence as far as physical
evidence that's where we fall short
would disagree with that have you ever
tried
a psychedelic compound i have not i mean
hey
we can figure this out pretty quick then
you do it and then you tell me it wasn't
real
well so you're saying that something you
take is gonna create an external
difference we can't look at that as
evidence any more than we can
i dream it widens perceptions of
consciousness but that's from your brain
that's like a hallucination that's not
really expanding consciousness like
you're talking about like hallucinating
what's the difference so i think science
is also based on perception
so you're talking about the brain and
the brain being powerful but so is our
heart center which science can prove
has its own energy field around it
and it's much stronger than our brain so
the point that i want to make is like
science is based on perception it's a
bunch of people perceiving studies a
certain way
right but so is spirituality the the
difference between science
is not that five different scientists
perceive something
differently or in the same way they look
at evidence and if that evidence
guides them and points them toward a
particular direction and it's repeatable
and it's falsifiable we tend to say well
that's what reality
tends to be or seems to be but that's
reality based on your perception no it's
not a perception
it is everything is perception science
is good
we're probably misinformed about a lot
of stuff but for the other side to say
you guys are misinformed i think is just
as
ridiculous because i think that's like
what i meant honestly is like we all
have our own truth
and that's relative to you and it's
valid regardless and i think and i think
that that can be true for people and i
think it's hard because i could show you
an expert it's meaningless to you but
you could show me your expert and it's
this is the right one and so it's
interesting because i work with a lot of
muslims they're saying you know i've
spoken to my god then a christian says
muslims god is wrong but i spoken to my
god hindu says you know i've actually
recognized and remembered my past life
and i have i can name it down to a t
and so if we get to that point i think
everyone would then just be right
and we know there would be no actual
unifying reality but the scientific
community is saying we want to create a
unified reality between each other so we
can progress
in our own way um and that's why science
we would never say there aren't
aliens or are aliens you know you're
saying aliens you know there was a crash
we would say there could be but we don't
know and
right now it's leaning this way so
misinformation is different it's more
just about
kind of like hard-headedness on that
it's fair i think it's more
close-mindedness to say
you know you yours a whole kind of
organization is is not to be malicious
in debunking things but
that that is your goal is is to disprove
something no that's not at all it's
absolutely not true well you you know no
no our
organization looks it's evidence for
things that we ask
others they have a claim of a paranormal
activity great show it to us
show us the evidence where we don't do
anything to debunk them
we simply that's really limiting though
no that's the thing
the information point just feel like
it's just
no limiting instead of missing well the
purpose is to find the truth to find the
truth and
when you say to the us navy who has come
out and said
there are unidentified flying crafts
that defy physics we don't know what
they are we don't know our physical but
the point of learning our physics
well i agree with that i think that's
why there's a lot of suppression in this
area because it unlocks it but if the us
is saying we don't know what it is
that's the point there's so many tapes
that you see from like the air force
where
you see these splaying objects i don't
know and that's the same thing of saying
you know five thousand years ago that's
thunder you guys saw that thunder it's
god
we're just saying we don't know and to
jump to but jumping into the conclusion
is kind of far we've kind of we've kind
of exploded but this is good
i am completely on the side of science
and
evidence i investigate claims of the
paranormal with a group called the
center for inquiry investigations group
and
um we have not found any evidence
whatsoever of
any sort of paranormal activity or
aliens or any of that sort of thing and
we've looked
and you've been on the show before right
i have been on the show before yes
in the flat earth episode nice what was
that experience like
it was a great experience my only
comment was that we presented a lot of
science and all of that was edited out
we sort of
ended up with interesting sound bites
but not so much of the science
well i'm sorry the area 51
raid was a bad idea
if you try to store military facilities
you're going to have a bad time
exactly if they can white people's
memories that have been working there
for 20 years
like like that then
what could they do to people that are
trying to storm a government facility
uh mow him down i mean that's literally
it i mean
i know it it i think it started as just
like a kind of a
joke facebook group or something like
that um
which is like okay that's kind of funny
but the fact that there is kind of a
somewhat of a consensus where at least
with skeptics that
people who do believe in aliens are
somewhat crazy or weird you know what i
mean like something's a little off with
them
so it was bad not only just for people
in general but also
believers in ufos and aliens in general
i definitely don't believe it was
necessarily a bad idea
i feel like it put pressure on the
government to be like hey there are a
lot of people who are
curious about what you're doing and if
you have a whole facility of just like
secrets you can't help but explore that
curiosity and see for yourself
and i definitely agree with that but it
wasn't like
we had a group of you know scientists
and
and well-to-do people that would be i
guess more respected
it was just a bunch of kids making jokes
about clapping alien cheeks you know
what i mean it's just like if there was
there was no seriousness behind it it
was the way it was constructed
i feel like religion or science can be
kind of limited
and boxed i have a catholic
background so in my family
aliens aren't real it's just human
beings so
growing up in that kind of environment
i should have a different opinion from
what i have now
i believe humans were created by a
higher power
you said humans right okay
it's clarifying i grew up as a catholic
and to now you know i've transitioned to
being a christian
and all of that um so i do believe in
god
i do believe that he created us and i
also believe he created everything else
the planet uh nature
the galaxy and beyond if the question
was
were we made by aliens i might not have
stepped forward but higher power is a
wider umbrella
we're clearly very different from every
other thing on this planet
right and i think there was some
intervention at some point
that might have facilitated that terence
mckenna thought it was mushrooms
that we did psychedelic mushrooms and
that facilitated an evolution of
consciousness and mushroom spores can
survive in space too so
maybe they are the aliens that helped us
get to where we are right now
so we are for sure an evolutionary
accident i mean
we don't know why we develop these big
brains but we did
i mean we've only been around kind of a
couple hundred thousand years yeah
actually kind of a piggyback off of that
where you know
as us as animals because that's
basically what we are we're just really
smart animals you know
it's just we took a path of how we
evolve to where we are today you know
and like you said with the the mushrooms
possibly being
part that's that would be part of the
evolution of what we are
it does change brain chemistry so let's
say that mushrooms it does but that
would
be more toward a lamarkian evolution as
opposed to a darwinian
evolution because lamarck thought that
if you just did
a pressure if you did forces then that
would change
different generations and we're pretty
sure that doesn't happen
i mean many many generations of jews
have been circumcising their babies and
yet every baby
has been born with a foreskin after that
so it's sort of
not something you can force apparently
but when we talked about higher power
i don't know well enough we just met but
i guarantee he wouldn't be
past saying yes aliens could have made
us you know
there could be civilizations that are
tens of thousands of years ahead of us
they could have came in here and altered
things that is 100 a possibility
um but possibility and probability are
two different things and i think that's
really important because
i can sit here all day and tell you yes
we could all be in a simulation
uh that is and statistically possible
but
statistically possible it's not how we
all operate our lives we use statistics
in everyday life and i think that's
really important to
not let it go when it comes to
everything else when it comes to
spiritual issues or evolution and to say
although i operate my entire life off
statistics i'm not going to do it here
i think there is some science that like
indicates like life on other planets or
like
you know going back to like ancient
civilizations there
is proof that like they believed in
aliens
but for me personally i would say it's
very spiritual based
my views on this topic are an important
part of my identity
it wouldn't make sense for me to not
step forward considering the fact that i
identify as a starseed
so it's just something that you awaken
to your own
divinity and it's very personal to you
and i think we're all in different paths
and
everyone's valid in their own way but
absolutely and when you have an
experience with it
it's about it's verified it's validated
but until you do
it's not there
it fascinates me you know i've watched
many documentaries many specials and
things like that regarding this topic
but
it's not like i live and breathe it you
know i'm not going to
dwell on it till it happens i'm not
going to worry about it too much i'd
love to be the first guy to
you know see the craft land go up
introduce myself you know get some alien
technology take my photos with my iphone
up close you know selfies i mean i would
love to do that
when you're ready yeah right exactly
ayahuasca
is a facilitator of contact made from
two plants in the amazon i've had a
friend do it and he
basically said that from that he he
found hinduism and he knows to be sure
that
reincarnation is real aliens aren't it's
all on earth
so that's why it's interesting because
it's like would you disagree with his
statement that there are no other aliens
it's just
hinduism and why would his trip be
different than yours and none
well i just consider the umbrella of
aliens to be more like non-human
intelligences whether it's
multi-dimensional something people
called spirits or angels or aliens
it doesn't seem like his experience
necessarily would devalue that
he might have a different box or label
i normally tell everyone i don't have
beliefs it's all based off statistics
i'm not here to say
100 percent there are aliens just
statistically there are
so i'm here to always just make the
boundary between people who say
100 there are aliens and the people who
say 100
there aren't aliens and i don't think
either of those are correct but we have
to look at it as a number situation and
i think that's very important because we
can't be using our emotion
or our religion to determine whether
there are aliens or not
to me it unlocked an entire dimension of
reality that i was denying beforehand
you know a spiritual dimension of
consciousness once you take these
compounds
you can experience things beyond
yourself that science is going to have a
tough time with
because science is in this box of the
material world there's so many things in
this world
that we we don't have any information on
so
almost kind of narcissistic in effect to
say we're the only intelligent beings
that live in this entire
known universe so yeah
no i think believe what you want but
aliens are real
i definitely agree with what you were
saying um
there's just too many things in this
world to just
have one single this is it
this is the truth idea um before my
spiritual awakening
i was just like you guys a hundred
percent and i was actually very atheist
someone like me who went through a
spiritual awakening
and someone who is a starseed and just
being like okay who
am i i'm not from here i could speak
this other language
like i can do these things that like
don't make any sense and having the kind
of experiences that i've had it's
something that
science can't explain to me and so i
feel like
just operating from a science base is
kind of limiting yourself
yeah and i think the misconception a lot
of people think that science is nothing
more than some weird collection of facts
and figures it's not that at all it's a
methodology
by which you explore the world the the
explore of the universe
but to give you an idea of how vast the
universe is you could take the smallest
grain of
dust paint it blue go out to the middle
of the pacific ocean throw it in there
and a year later tell your friend
go find that grain of dust that would be
much easier
to find than to find the earth in this
universe if you didn't know where to
look for the earth
i mean we are so small and insignificant
compared to a grain of dust in the
pacific ocean
i think we all kind of agree aliens
probably do exist there's a great chance
for me 99.99 you know percent chance
here it's just a fine line when we talk
about
you know psychedelics or inner you know
realities because i think then we have
to credit people with schizophrenia
we have to credit people with all types
of disorders to then not downplay what
they believe and what they see and they
see their
mother walking in front of them and they
see the ants that actually evolve into
humans in front of them and
so i think it's hard to do that because
i think if we go down that realm or that
realm then we can't discredit them
either not to say we can't but just it
would put us down that realm where we
have to credit all of them and so it's
really important that for me
is yes we can go down that road but i
think that road didn't lead us to cars
hospitals different things like that
thanks guys yeah thank you that's good
yeah it's great meeting all of you
you too wonderful thank you
wow that was a trip have you ever
been in contact with an alien i have not
i am pretty sure i believe in aliens
elon musk is an alien oh yeah that was a
prompt that we
initially were gonna have in the video
and we ended up not asking it for time
i wish we had included that one i
haven't met him though so i still have
not contacted an alien
a big thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this episode for those of you
who don't know
skillshare is an online learning
community where creative and
curious people can come together to try
new things gain new skills
a class that i really like is called
real productivity how to build habits
that last
by author and fellow youtuber thomas
frank
so i like the class because the first
thing he hits you with is the idea that
perfect is the enemy of good and that's
something we talk a lot about at jubilee
we all want to do great work we all want
to make something perfect but if we
really just focus on that
end goal it's really hard to start so
with that said
the first 1000 subscribers who click on
the link in the description below
will get a two month free trial of
skillshare
premium and as always stay
safe and like comment and subscribe and
like comment and subscribe
both of those things yeah he said
earthlings bye